welcome back to the ftth conference here
in the Stockholm and stockin's messin
with me with me now I have understood by
the head of communication at Stoke up
and we are going to talk a little bit
about fiber in the Nordics and FTTH in
the Nordics which is a seminar where you
were participating in earlier today
anglers we're during the specific topics
you were talking about we've been
talking little bit about FTTH in Nordics
a few times earlier here in the studio
but not we haven't heard what you spoke
about at the seminar no I'm coming from
Stoke gave us you say and it's infra
infrastructure company in Stockholm yeah
I'll try this town so Nordic it's a big
area and and we are focused on the stock
on dr. area with all that challenge and
so on but my headline was related to
that if you want to succeed with a
broadband bear fibre rollout it's very
important to separate a different level
from each other so in our case we are
just providing the dark fiber the
passive infrastructure and nothing else
and then it's open from everywhere on
equal terms okay because we don't really
think that's will be you will have such
great rule out competition and so on
innovation if your traditional operators
you who have everything from the cable
to the service is this anything you can
do everywhere you think or is this a
specific thing you can do only in
Stockholm no I don't think so because if
you look at other infrastructure like
the road
the rail wailing stone it's it's quite
natural that they'd separate from the
service yeah a lot of reasons and higher
i have really oh I don't understand why
it's a lot of places where you think
that you need to be you know both
infrastructure and the service and
that's the only Moodle yeah so I would
say it's it's it's a could definitely be
used everywhere but then of course go
from one situation to another situation
that could also be tricky and and you
must take it if from the easiest ways to
begin with a structure like this yes I
have a say that i would say that because
it's a infrastructure in this case it's
a long-term investment and then you need
to be long term and to be able to be to
be that is that you're not dealing with
lot of service who can could be the
customer could like and then next year
they don't like and so on so it's better
to have just rude and then it's up to to
everyone to to use it then you'll be
able to get your money do income and to
spread out network more and more and
more and then you get more and more
customer and so on and ya know are there
many many cities using this model or are
you alone in in a market sweden have 219
municipal and and you have city networks
in 180 of this but then the the moodle
could be little different yeah they are
big difference between it's us windy yes
many of these city networks also have
level 2 lighting up your fiber and
giving so so but common is that it to
really try to be as low as possible it's
it open for everyone and so on so okay
and then also if you compare with
different cities in sweden stockholm is
extremely big comparing with other shuts
its so it's a
one you're often a case internationally
there are many international countries
and yes it is a stuff comes to Sweden to
visit and see you because you have been
very successful yes at what I've said it
coming for three things the first thing
is they are like that we had creates so
much competition we have over 100
operators who active and using our net
for your business we have a lot of over
700 total different customer who's using
it and the second reason is that they
are amazing that a public own company
could run without tax money yeah that
seems very curious for a lot of people
but it's not really not any problem
because we have it's very common that
just sit in Stockholm in Sweden have
company to provide water for example and
the water is not paid by the tax monies
paid by the users who pay for the water
and it's the same here the customer is
paying to rent in the fiber and because
we haven't built everything at once we
have bill step by step and we saved
money you must have started somewhere
yes yes your tax money somewhere in the
beginning no it to a creating a company
it's cuz the five thousand euro and then
it's the city yes they pay but then we
day one go to bank and say we want to
buy we want to have money borrow 10
because we going to build the
infrastructure fiber infrastructure and
they Bank say yes this okay because to
reason you're not buying so much money
because you just building a little bit
to start with and anyway it's new so
such a big risk and a second of course
when we have the the city as owner it's
quite safe in with ya saved investment
Adele and then we have we are building
and we get customer get revenue cash
flow and so on and then it's it's very
easy to go to the bank and say now we
want to expand our network we want to
borrow some more and I see our books and
see it work well and then you can go on
yeah you have a quite good revenue today
you have of today yes
more than thirty percent which you all
invest all the money back in the company
yes because well first we start we start
in 94 yes we have been twenty year now
and you're like back 94 was like back in
the Stone Age okay yeah yeah yeah it
comes to broadcast yes this was
yesterday in India as a consequence of
the deregulation in the Swedish telecom
market so we started 94-98 we have the
first benefit of profit but it was first
2008 we start earn more money than we
have really spent okay so it is really
time and of course we have a lot of
investment that we want to have back in
that case yes and any rules for in
Sweden for for company for cities own
companies was a three main reason you
must have some mission in our case
provide dark fiber in the area you must
be quite close to the two area so we're
not allowed to expand to other countries
or far away in the Sweden's will be
being stuck on region and the third is
that you allowed to get much your profit
you want and until even as long you you
take the profit back in investing in the
company in the inner so but if you when
we have sometimes maybe stop in western
and pay the loan then we must have lower
price for products that's that's
interesting that sounds really good so
what are you investing in today we have
we'll wait before beginning a 94 until
2007-2008 is mainly business-to-business
and then we have really focused the last
year to fiber to your home that we have
connected ninety percent of the building
our their buildings were ninety percent
of households is living yeah and then it
was quite heavy invest but our say DCC
obviously normally said it's is three
business in the same case you have the
households who is very slow to really
order and decide but you also have a lot
of small enterprise who avoid quite
quick quickly to say
we have fiber now I want to really good
broadband and then you have all the
mobile operator who need to spread out
and net below the network and we are
quite good so it's a but you built out
this network on a chance you can say
because you didn't have customers in in
all these apartments and houses and
stuff like that yes we just connected
yes yeah do you see see it exploding
today or are we climbing slow on the
penetration well yes and no I would say
we always think that next year will not
be so much fiber you need but it always
be more and more demand from our
customer more and more fiber and sis and
even if they the end customer for
example household don't need a fiber
connection they need to operators
deliver broadband for the forum need
fiber wear it loose to our links for
example the cable company need fiber
very very close and then it changed to
the it quacks cable cable and so to be
able set so and and definitely it's
going up but it's hard to see how
quickly Joanne and and so but my opinion
vetted everyone needs fiber connection
simulator you can't be out in the future
no so we having this event in Stockholm
yes this year you were in London last
year yes if you compare the events oh
well of course I proudly see stuck on
yeah yes yeah well it's it's I think
both function well for me it's very
interesting to walking around and listen
to different speakers and hear about
trends and best practices and and so on
them to find to figure out what's going
on and handler and I would say it's it
was both really interested in London and
it's a lot of interesting speakers here
so though but you're having your own
event that friday after does the
conference's yes over yes how come
you're having an event and what will it
is it's a
one reason is that we are 20 year and
celebrate so we think it's good idea to
have a seminar to share ideas instead of
giving ice cream to the children and we
will focus on we have really interesting
speakers from New Zealand the Singapore
United States and they have been durable
so and try to see what happened in
different part of the world and what
could we since we'd and Europe learn
from each other to to find try to be
even better to rule out fibre and and
basic infrastructure you need to be a
good Society yeah lots of people coming
yes today it's in the morning it was
over 200 that's still still yes you're
still counting yes you're still counting
and we think it's a good idea to have it
for some papers coming to this
conference could stay one more day and
take this also yeah and also some of the
speakers were really interesting to come
when we can offer to go to this
conference before oh yeah yeah you were
also stuck on assault also very recently
named as the network societies city of
the world or something like that yes
Erickson have a lot of different company
who make different ranking an index and
so on and this ottoman in november
ericsson present the most connected city
and Stocking would ranked it number one
yeah it's very pleasure and I guess your
report or the lists two very big part of
that yes yeah it's in fact because the
Erickson says that it was the reason the
the well build out fibre network the
high Jews and well 4G LTE network and
use by you me and another here using ICT
solutions own is Sweden really a good
example of a fiber nation well yes i
know i will say the cities are more good
example
I said would you say the government here
could do definitely more they have not
done smells so much i would say in what
way thinking them i think well for first
what they have done is to present
broadband statutory 2009 it's a good
step but this program status a well i
was sake we should be good on broadband
and nothing else it's just I would say
nice word of course this had put debate
and force I want to do more but now we
really need broadband saturate to dot
second were some new words and who is
taking higher goals for this mute to
meet a few just one reason the second
reason I've said it they are because the
government is the big owner of the
incumbent ilha de like more to have
profit from the from Julia back in the
in the state's cash flow than building
out fiber so they the government is
reading could learn a lot of the cities
in Sweden to promote and really expand
accelerate the rollout in instant in
Sweden and a third reverse ad the
Swedish parliament have some years ago
also say to decision is that the
government should come back with
proposal how they are going to split
talia the infrastructure part from the
service but the government do nothing
just lazy one else can we say well we
have no hurry to to to go do that
Parliament I decide do you know why it
is like that no I don't know but I think
it is quite easy to have a company who
given a lot of profit back to the to the
state to to the state so analyst and
then it's always tricky to change no way
regardless what type of change your
doing
we're having a new election this autumn
do you think that this that could change
the game well new election a new
government regardless scholar it's it's
always a new opportunity to take a new
questions and from a new winger angle in
stone but unfortunately I will say this
it's this type of question is not
anything that will just really have a on
the top of mind so it's I am more
hopeful that the lot of the Swedish
municipal are really discussing how we
can have fiber a large to our citizens
and to be able to live a lot of service
to receipts and more effington FS 70
yeah so we're reaching at the end of the
first day of the seminar are you looking
forward to anything special for the rest
of the day or tomorrow tomorrow really
looking for one other session where
other girl mr. are the ground by from
Swedish television is talking about how
they have developed TV production based
on fiber and it's reduced it cost forty
percent and and and a lot of other good
things are really interesting to hear
how are you working with that and how it
works is going on okay thank you very
much for coming under special to have
you here good luck and that means we are
going on to our last speakers for today
as you can see behind us there are lots
of people out moving around looking at
the
the show here and as you might know you
can also watch the whole seminar show at
streaming at FTTH conference dot EU you
know I welcome Maria hell the CEO of
sunnah to the student network I guess it
is here in Sweden and Jurgen sounds from
IT strategists at skl sounds good yes so
how do we translate skl 22 english it's
their association for the local and
regional authorities yeah both of you
have been in the panel about smart
everything hmm is Sweden a smart place
to be well I think so yes actually as
soon as the stands for the Swedish
university that works so that was
actually mainly what I was talking about
them do you need of the dark fiber for a
sec actually establishing our network
between the universities and the
research projects and so on so that was
actually my main thing which is actually
kind of a base condition for for
everything else that will happen that
for instance your again we're talking
about all the small things that need
need to happen is well that will happen
it needs to infrastructure yeah that was
my kind of my contributor to the
dialogue for the debate and dark fiber
is also something you are keen to talk
about your agonda of course it's a it's
a new infrastructure infrastructure in
this society and it is like the our new
roads and our you airports and so on so
so we needed to develop to reach the
goals for growth and jobs in the society
but we also have to fail it with with
good public services at this in the same
rate that that we are can we see that
market is failing it with with the new
media services for television and
and other stuff other useful stuff that
everybody uses today since I know both
of you are working quite much with the
dark fiber could you please explain to
me and to the viewer so what's so good
with the dark fiber compared to two
wavelengths fiber hmm well actually
sorry I do you watch it man okay men's
first I was going to say okay anyway no
but well every level in the value chain
has its own policy and needs its own
policy and it's necessary for certain
things so if you go deep down in the
value chain you have the dark fiber and
for that you can put on optical
equipment or hardware to make
wavelengths and then you can about the
wavelengths you can make IP order to
make internet or IP connections yeah and
of course the lower you get of course
the more own equipment can you do on
your own solutions and for instance our
research proj as in sweden well
sometimes they need just plainly an
internet connection and we provide that
of course but sometimes they need just a
transport raw data and then of course
they need to have what if I couldn't
communication that's at a very low level
in the value chain and for that we need
a dark fiber and we need our own with
quit before doing that but for other
solutions okay that might be necessary
or or interesting or relevant to have
like transmissions solutions for for
other purposes or even IP connectivity
to two other operators but that depends
on what you're doing and the stuff that
we doing needs a diversity of this
institution so we need a dog fiber for
doing that oh yeah
I think that that my point of view is
the citizens the businesses and the
public sectors needs all around the
country in every house in every bush
almost they have different they have
needs to develop they have needs for
their daily life they have a lot of
needs and we have to see that that we
have a food future-proof infrastructure
for that to provide those services that
we will have and will need for the
future and so for me it's it's it's
basically about getting an
infrastructure out there so it can be
used to to get better services to
enhance competition to be a part of
developing the growth and the jobs and
electricity attractivity that these
municipalities did these cities need for
the daily daily life and I I think if
you do believe that we on wavelength or
or dark fiber that could that is a
question of semantics for me basically
because it's about what what what can
how can we do it right there right now
and and if we have a situation like
install condom dark fiber is the perfect
solution probably for that done and I
can see that is can be used much more
than it is today but we know that
wavelength is some kind of middle thing
about you have to use the infrastructure
even better and yeah we will see where
it ends up we talk a lot about the
Swedish infrastructure we have a
fantastic infrastructure here when it
comes to fiber and when it helps the
broad but services are we is good on
services as we are on building networks
in Sweden well well I was the mobile or
and yeah versity yes I could in in
demanding high actually speed it's a
it's a good driver it's a good driver
from the research sector emphasis from
the steward at the universities that's a
very very good rival amix but that is
the way it started in the beginning of
the 80s actually what unit is like over
so two years old so
so it's been it was and it's still a big
driver a good rider for a four cylinder
and I as I understand over thirty
percent of the kids are looking at the
children's channel on on internet
instead of going to the television so
they have already adopted the new
technology and think that the the iPads
or whatever is is probably a better
choice than done then looking at it the
old way so the storage the students and
the kids they are the best on using
services I think that if you give them
something they use it return yeah
exactly there are no boundaries there so
so what about services for elderly
people I mean mmm so all that's over 25
yeah when you ended up studying yeah but
I think that the the the newly retires
if you we see a rather large group today
that has quite a good situation quite
good quite a lot of money they want to
travel a lot they were to have some some
good time on the rail when when they
knew Larry tried they actually use a lot
of the internet for for both looking at
the media services or during their the
travels did they do a lot of stuff they
are actually quite quite digitalized
today so I think that that in different
groups you can see quite widely when it
comes to e-learning and e-health that's
do you transfer really coming up on the
agenda internationally now are we good
in Sweden argue bad I think we have good
research in suite now I think we have a
lot of interesting projects but I can't
see it on a daily basis i think that the
public sector is actually quite bad on
on yeah that taking advantage of the new
technology i'm adopting it adopting yeah
exactly and also amusing or being better
procure actually a la doc say because in
many sense this is in many cases are
sorry it has to do it being a good
procure as you can kind of get
solutions with good standardizations
with good standards and secure solutions
and I don't think according to what I'm
seeing during my 10 years the government
and also before working for the
municipality they could be better pick a
procurer actually and and and that would
that would probably produce all a lot of
solutions sell a lot of problems but i
would like to combine the discussion
about having more services and and on
the network and also the development on
on the network itself i think i like one
area but to try to raise it now and I
have my my speech in the session and
that's actually it's like saying we need
more roads and everybody okay we need
more rows we need more optical fiber but
if the roads were owned by certain
different companies i'ma free instead
Essene service is coming to your home
via the fiber to the home but what if
that fiber is not accessible for the
service full of some some kind of
operator that would actually serve the
service provide the service so that's
what I mean I mean we have to kind of
include the openness of the fiber in the
discussion not only that we need more
fiber because that is completely
everybody I think agree agrees on that
one that is not an issue any longer no
no exact no he's of course you can talk
about them investments who is going to
invest and how would you be salt blah
blah blah these kind of things but how
do we make it opus it's really
accessible so it's like roads and rail
Rosen and even though we're doing this
optical fiber you know development for
so many years we don't dare to touch
that elephant in the room how do we make
this fiber open accessible I think
that's random do you have a solution hmm
I told that the session you've out there
no but I think we need to be a bit more
open to to regulation like having
optical the dark optical fiber as a
whole side product in the whole Europe
and I know that's going to cause a lot
of the discussions and people go oh
nobody's going to invest in that
tenement I don't think so actually I
don't think so because we did the copper
the copper regulation the local loop
regulates bitstream regulation and that
was quite successful I have to say so we
have to try to need to tackle this
optical fiber may be in the same way
it's also an infrastructure so it's I
know it's tricky but I think some kind
of regulation would be in place hmm
you're not on Maria side you're good no
I don't think so we don't think that we
can regulate the success especially when
it's an infrastructure where we have
about eighty percent left to build with
the corporate was different because one
hundred percent of it was built and and
here we have to promote actually promote
investments and so on but i think you
have right in one way that we have to
talk about this asset raring and how to
actually how to actually use the
infrastructure that is put in place and
can be used and and also talked about
this openness and and not least net
neutral neutrality and and give good
frames for how to develop this in the
future so so so it doesn't feel like a
big risk to invest in this should you do
wait should we wait for 10 or 20 years
before we open up the networks for
everyone open up with nothing I think
you can open it up anyway and and and
for instance if we have publicly owned
networks in some extent so that a market
feel feels forced to open their own
networks to be part of it it's one way
of doing it as well and I think we can
actually see that situation in Sweden
where a lot of publicly owned fiber
actually guarantees that even the
monopolists the incumbent have to talk
about it have it as a business model
with with openness but I realized that
this could be a tricky thing for other
countries in Europe and we have to help
them of course an attitude and and
regulation is like it's like it's not
the best word for me I don't think that
you can regulate success but but still I
understand that we have to have some
kind of guidelines that promotes exactly
what you agree with you so your goal I
think you agree yeah maybe methods could
be
okay yeah well actually I've you know I
stopped working for the government a
year ago so I feel I don't have to be
pulled so political correct you know I
don't have a political leadership as you
have actually I do have that okay but
anyway but it's far away yeah no but i
agree with you i mean in regulation is
kind of the last tool you have to their
money many are many other tools you can
actually the software tools or like
stimulating and having strategies talk
about it kind of have it have a goal
that you want to have the optical fiber
as a wholesale product and kind of make
that that you know it's true and and
then it might might happen in other ways
because of although it's just happening
its service when you talk about the
thing enough times it suddenly comes
through and i think what you're saying
also having other you know publicly
owned networks as a competitor that are
all that have open networks of course
they force the other networks to open up
with themselves so I mean there are many
tools but we need to talk about this and
we need to have this strategy and we
don't right now actually yeah we're
we're actually falling back to an
infrastructure they start discussion but
we were here to talk about smart
everything oh yeah but yeah I know I
know then yeah that's irritating yeah
it's that does that look at it look
around you see optical fibers all over
the place at the seminar was it the same
way at the seminar where you were pardon
no I no I don't think so I don't think
so now I've heard really good smart
everything cases well you were talking
about many things I think in your speech
I I think that that the public sector
have to step up and deliver more good
services that actually take this this
opportunity that we have with the
infrastructure in use more and better
and a lot of a lot of things is
happening for instance this the
development in the Swedish schools are
incredible when you see to the amount on
computers & Wireless zones they have and
all the fire but that
you have to have to give them the this
possibility and so there are a lot of
things going on actually but it's not
happening as fast as it should and we
can do even more to provide better
services for the signal citizen and they
actually asked for it because now they
are so used to using it in so many other
areas that I think that why should it
have why can't you I get a building
permit right here right now because it's
what's the problem about giving me a
building permit right here right now and
we have something about you know
agencies and low and sir but it's that
basically it's not true because it's
about just to have the information you
need and process it to see can I build
or can I not build yeah and and that is
basically how easy it is but we have to
cooperate a lot more we have to to talk
with each other much more we have to
realize that that this is about the
daily life life of people and not about
my silo where I have responsibilities
just to look in this I have to look at
myself and say what role do I have in in
the society's future and in Orion this
we're in the people's daily life so so
what we come back to is if we're going
to have a smart everything line we need
the infrastructure own place we have a
trustee infrastructure yeah exactly and
that it was was also a topic during our
session that we're where we it must be
resilient it must be robust it must work
yeah because exact if we trust it with
our lives it can't go down every time
the lights go out no no have to work you
know that's true mmm so I guess you've
been busy the whole day today I'm here
looking forward to have a peaceful day
tomorrow or maybe later today or is it
anything special you're out watching for
for the rest of the ftth conference well
I for me it's an opportunity to meet up
with a lot of people that I don't meet
so
often and talk about their their issues
basically so it's yes it'll be the same
sign for me actually to meet a lot of
people i haven't met for a long time
because i was more in the broad about
sector before and then i work for the
government so now I coming back in the
in the secretary can say is more like
reconnected with a with a bunch of
people that's that's that's really nice
that the networking is a very important
part of this it's working it's very
round for you always on any layer it
doesn't matter if it's on the fiber
level or on the human exactly same
networking so pleasure to have you here
both of you thank you very much
appreciated thank you very much lucky ok
so we are ending up so this day's show
from our little studio here at the floor
of FTTH conference at Stoke owns my cell
it's fantastic to just walk around and
feel the atmosphere more than 3,000
delegates from 84 countries it's so
fantastic and we'll be back tomorrow at
eleven ten on the first coffee break
here at this event and until then thank
you for watching
you